Senator John McCain dies the media
rewrites history and a mass shooting
takes place in Jacksonville we'll talk
all about it I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show a somber weekend with
the death of Senator John McCain dead at
the age of 81 he died on Saturday I
found out about it right after Sabbath I
have a lot of thoughts also there's a
lot of fallout in the media sphere in
the political sphere we will get to all
of that first let's talk about your gun
rights the reality is that law abiding
citizens ought to have guns that are to
protect themselves from criminals and
from folks who'd want to violate their
rights this is why you ought to have a
gun too and this is your last chance
because if you'd like to hit the range
tomorrow with a brand new gun the u.s.
CCA wants to give you a free gun right
now they're giving away a different gun
every single day it ends Friday so you
are almost out of time just go to defend
your family now calm to get entered
right now you could get up to 17 chances
to win a new gun every day it could be
17 Kimber 17 Glocks maybe even that new
Sig Sauer but they are all gone on
Friday all you have to do is go to
defend your family now calm to reveal
the gun you could take home today it's
totally free remember not a lot of time
the gunner of the day always disappears
at midnight and it all ends Friday again
so hurry this is your absolute last
chance to take home one of these guns as
a law-abiding citizen you should know
how to use a gun and you should know how
to protect yourself and should have the
weaponry to do so go to defend your
family now calm to get entered to win
your free gun right now that's defending
your family now calm again defend your
family now calm the u.s. CCA does
amazing educational work also you can go
enter to win that freak on at all ends
on Friday defend your family now calm so
the big story over the weekend obviously
was the death of Senator John McCain
Senator McCain served for I believe 35
years in the Senate he became famous not
because of that but because he did five
years in a North Vietnamese prison from
the man truly was an American Hero
despite the fact that there are many who
would say otherwise for no reason other
than petty spite the fact is that anyone
who serves in uniform and then does five
years in a North Vietnamese prison and
then gives up their opportunity to come
home in order to maintain a solidarity
with the troops who are already there
that is an American Hero John McCain did
two years in solitary confinement under
the North Vietnamese under the Vietcong
when he came out he had essentially been
physically crippled his hair was
completely
here's a clip of john mccain talking
about his his torture at the hands of
the of the north vietnamese historians
have said that no american prisoner
arrived at the Hanoi Hilton in worse
condition than McCain broke my shoulder
and hurt my knee again and but look I
don't blame them I don't blame them
we're in a war I don't didn't like it
but at the same time were it when you're
in a war and you're captured by the
enemy you can't expect you know to to
have tea and so when he was he
crash-landed on the North Vietnamese
denied him medical aid and they stabbed
with a bayonet as well then they
proceeded to torture him for years and
years and years for information and then
they tried to leverage and they tried to
use him as a propaganda tool they wanted
to return him to the United States
because his father was an admiral and
thereby create the narrative that the
United States gave preferential
treatment to the children of the
privileged McCain turned that down and
instead stayed under the gentle mercies
of one of the worst regimes in history
the Vietcong that is American heroism he
then came back and he he answered the
Senate I believe in it woulda been 1981
and he was he was there for 36 years he
died over the weekend now does this mean
that everything that John McCain did was
amazing politically no I disagreed with
John McCain routinely most recently when
John McCain gave the thumbs down to what
they called skinny repealed the repeal
of large parts of the Obamacare package
including the individual mandate and he
said he did that because he didn't
approve of the way the Senate was
running he was a guy who was constantly
talking about the rules of the Senate
even though the Democrats were
constantly breaking those rules but John
McCain overall understood that America
was an exceptional place and he put his
life on the line in order to prove that
America was an exceptional place he
certainly understood the threat that was
posed to America by outside actors he
understood the threat that was posed to
America by places like Russia there's a
reason that Russia today basically ran a
bunch of smears against him or ignored
him after his death none of that is
particularly a shock Sarah Huckabee
Sanders actually said that John McCain
was an American Hero she was caught up
with by TMZ as she left Reagan National
Airport she said
Kane's death was a great loss for our
country and then she was asked if she
personally plans to attend the funeral
and she said absolutely
apparently vice-president pence will
attend the funeral Donald Trump will not
attend the funeral because he has a
long-standing spat
with John McCain Barack Obama and George
W Bush are both expected to speak at the
funeral and I want to talk a little bit
in a second about the sort of reason why
there are so many people on the trumpian
right who are very angry at John McCain
there are a lot of people who are
trashing his memory the day of his death
and I don't think that that is
appropriate in any way shape or form
President Trump did tweet after senator
McCain's death my deepest sympathies in
respect go out to the family of Senator
John McCain our hearts and prayers are
with you but obviously President Trump
was not a fan of Senator McCain and that
goes all the way back to early in the
campaign when he suggested that Senator
McCain was not a war hero which was an
abominable statement I mean by any
standard for Donald Trump to say a guy
who avoided the Vietnam draft and then
bragged about how his own personal
Vietnam had been avoiding STDs during
the 1970s while sleeping with various
and sundry women for him to say that
John McCain was not a war hero because
he hadn't been caught is because he
because he'd been caught is was an
egregious statement obviously and led to
a tremendous rift between McCain and
Trump from the very beginning according
to the Washington Post press secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders chief of staff
John Kelly and other White House aides
advocated for an official statement that
gave the decorated Vietnam War powa
audits for his military and Senate
service and called him a hero according
to current and former White House aides
who requested anonymity to discuss
sensitive internal deliberations the
original statement was drafted before
McCain died Saturday Sanders and others
edited a final version this weekend that
was ready for the president the aide
said but Trump told aides he wanted to
post a brief tweet instead and the
statement praising McCain's life was not
released so despite the fact that Trump
had released official statements on the
death of John Glenn former senator he
refused to do so for John McCain and
Trump has no plans apparently to attend
McCain's funeral this is generating all
sorts of media headlines it's stupid
politics by the president it is just
from a political perspective but he's
dumb politics by the president because
he is reopening a rift in the aftermath
of a guy's death that is completely
unnecessary showing a little bit of
grace would probably be a much better
move here and this was exacerbated this
morning by the fact that President Trump
ordered the flags at the White House to
be re hung at the top of the staff so
the
normal rule but so by federal statute
the rule is that when a senator dies
that the flag is lowered for about a day
but the unofficial rule and this is the
one that we've kept too is that when a
sitting senator dies what you do is you
leave the the flag at half-staff until
the senator is actually buried if you
look at the pictures of the White House
you can see that the flag is back up to
top of the staff and I think the most
troubling picture obviously was there's
a picture of the the White House flag at
the top of the staff and there's another
picture that showed behind that you can
see the Washington Memorial the
Washington Monument rather and you can
see all the flags are at half staff so
while the White House is back up to top
of the staff the Washington Monument
they're still down at half-staff which
makes the president look really petty
whether or not you like John McCain
whether you like Donald Trump better
than John McCain it is irrelevant
this is not good politics it makes the
president look petty it makes him look
silly and there's no reason for him to
do any of that now the president's
honesty is one of the attributes that
people like about him it would have
looked dishonest if the President had
called McCain a war hero had called him
a war hero after not calling him a hero
and after ripping him up and down but to
issue some sort of gracious statement
and take the temporary hit I think would
have been well worthwhile I want to talk
about McCain's record in just a second
and why there's a perception on parts of
the right that this sort of kind of slap
it and McCain is is a is a decent thing
that it's not a huge deal but let's
flashback to a couple of things about
John McCain that I think are relevant
first of all let's talk about his record
so there's been a lot of talk today
about the things that John McCain's did
right and the things that John McCain
did wrong I would say that John McCain
was right on about 65% of issues and
who's wrong and about 35% of issues
those 35% loomed very large right
campaign finance reform was a case where
I was in deep disagreement with John
McCain I think that his plans for
campaign finance reform were actually
quite harmful to the American public
debate I think frankly they were
unconstitutional but John McCain pushed
those through anyway he was as I say
instrumental in upholding part of
Obamacare just in the last year alone
his his tenure was not unmarked on
traversée obviously his his henan tenure
began an 87 rather I said 81 earlier as
January 1987 and he had some problems
with scandal he was involved with the
so-called Keating 5 Charles Keating was
a banker that McCain had met while
working at Hensley and company and
Keating's associates at the Lincoln
Savings and Loan
give them money to McCain as well as
five other senators Keating supported
them in the hopes of preventing the
government seizures of his savings and
loan McCain participated in meetings
there was never any finding of serious
corruption there but McCain would later
go on to sponsored campaign finance
reform obviously McCain Feingold became
a real thorn in the side of a lot of
politicians and as I say I think a
violation of First Amendment principles
when McCain was very instrumental in the
kind of war movement in the aftermath of
9/11 I think that was right I think
McCain's statements with regard to the
surge in Iraq or eminently correct I
think who's more correct on foreign
policy than he was on domestic policy
but McCain did win the New Hampshire
primaries in January 8 2008 he ran a
campaign against Barack Obama that I
thought was quite luck well lackluster
but the things about McCain that made
McCain a class act in certain ways were
things like this so people are pointing
out this clip this is from the 2008
campaign McCain was at a town hall event
and a woman gets up and she calls Obama
a Muslim and McCain basically says no no
no we're not doing that I can't trust
Obama I I have read about him and he's
not he's not he's a he's an Arab he is
not no no ma'am no ma'am he's a he's a
he's a decent family man citizen that I
just happened to have disagreements with
on fundamental issues and that's what
this campaign is all about he's not
thank you and that was sort of who
McCain was McCain had a baseline of good
sense to him when it came at least to
relationships with other people in
politics but it's exactly that that led
a lot of people to kind of dismiss him
on the right because the reality is in
2008 he did run a lackluster campaign he
ran a campaign where he refused to say
truths about Barack Obama including
about Barack Obama's associations with
Jeremiah Wright and Bill Ayers it was a
lackluster campaign he shouldn't have
lost that campaign he did lose that
campaign because I think that his sense
of honor and politics overwhelmed his
necessity for victory in politics and
you can say some good things about that
you can also say some bad things about
that but it led to the feeling that the
Republican Party wasn't fighting hard
enough so what we really need is a
counter-puncher and so people who favor
Trump over McCain in that battle are
largely relying on the fact that McCain
was seen as sort of milquetoast in the
way that he went after other politicians
whereas Donald Trump is
as a guy who'll go no-holds-barred now I
want to talk about the media reaction to
John McCain in just a second because in
some ways I think that it is quite
revealing about who the media are when
it comes to Republicans generally but
first let's talk about your personal
comfort so there are a lot of ways in
life that you can feel rich without
having to be rich and one of those ways
is zeal comm you go to zeal it's their
iPhone Android app it's zeal Zeo and you
can select from top local licensed
pre-screened massage therapists you can
choose your favorite technique gender
preference time and location for your
massage zeal then sends one of their
10,000 licensed massage therapists with
a massage table music and supplies to
give you that five-star massage
scheduling booking payment it is fast
and easy
even the tip has included seven days a
week 365 days a year
as the Oh massage therapist can be a to
your door and as little as an hour so
it's supremely convenient I've used it
for myself for my wife for my in-laws
for my parents for my sister it really
is fantastic there's a reasons Yale has
been featured in The Wall Street Journal
the New York Times Vogue and on Good
Morning America bring the spa - you try
seal today today like their on demand so
you can do it like right now to help you
get started our listeners can get twenty
five bucks off their first massage with
promo code been that seal spelled z ee l
comm promo code been right now go to
zeal calm we're on seals iPhone or
Android app get a special offer when you
try seal today enter promo code Ben it's
get twenty-five bucks off your first
in-home massage deal is a fantastic
service you should try them out it's
sealed calm and use that promo code Ben
you get twenty five bucks off your first
in home at massage so well there while
the media are fulminating over the fact
that President Trump is disrespectful to
John McCain which is true the media are
suddenly experiencing a strange new
respect for John McCain the media
suddenly loved John McCain and I'd like
to remind you that in 2008 while John
McCain was running an honorable campaign
against Barack Obama the media were
calling him a racist they were calling
him a sexist they were suggesting that
he was a crazed old loon who was going
to land the United States in the middle
of interminable war right that was their
campaign against John McCain I remember
I was there I helped raise money for the
McCain campaign John McCain the heroes
AAA this kind of encapsulated Lester
Spence was an assistant professor of
political science at the Johns Hopkins
University he said this about Senator
John McCain's campaign rhetoric Senator
John McCain's recent attacks on Barack
Obama accusing him of being a terrorist
which McCain never did combine with GOP
columnists and bloggers arguing that
Obama supports painting the White House
black
and racial reparations represents an
embrace of the problematic Southern
Strategy the GOP has historically used
to increase white racial resentments had
spends who's african-american but as can
be seen in the most recent presidential
debate he's employing the strategy
selectively only among the GOP faithful
and that was the take of the media at
the time there are a lot of people in
the media who are suggesting that John
McCain was just as bad as they suggest
Donald Trump is today the media
routinely say whoever is the Republican
who is running for office now every
other Republican before has been decent
you wait after Donald Trump is out of
office whether it's in four years or
whether it's in eight years there will
be an the next person who they nominate
the next person Republicans pick will be
seen as worse than Donald Trump
there are you saying right they say
there they say about Mike Pence and if
Donald Trump were to be somehow depose
from office and Mike Pence were to take
his slot be careful what you wish for
because Mike Pence is more dangerous and
even more scary than Donald Trump
it is because the left slandered folks
like John McCain who was a moderate on
politics and John McCain was a moderate
Republican at best they slandered him
let's let Mitt Romney another moderate
on politics and moderate Republican at
best they slandered both of them as
racist sexist bigoted homophobes and the
Republican base responded by saying both
of those guys were nice guys who refused
to run a bare-knuckles campaign against
the Democrat so let's nominate the not
nice guy who's happy to go bare knuckles
that says it there's a to to
underestimate the effect that Democratic
attacks on John McCain and Mitt Romney
had on the 2016 primaries is to ignore
reality there are a lot of Republicans
who resonated to the fact that Donald
Trump was willing to take a hammer to
anyone specifically because they said
well we nominated a couple of genteel
folks and we had a genteel president
george w bush and you guys hammered the
living daylights out of those folks so
why wouldn't we nominate somebody like
Donald Trump now the cost of that is
that you end up with somebody like
Donald Trump as president in terms of
character who will also slander John
McCain but none of that is to is to I
think to grade the fact that the media's
attacks on Republicans like McCain led
to the rise of folks like Donald Trump
we're gonna talk in a second about what
exactly the media said upon John
McCain's death because suddenly it was a
different to so first of all I have to
point this out this was the best gaffe
of the weekend it was truly amazing
NBC News broke into Saturday Night Live
in order to announce John McCain's death
and let's just say that there programmer
is
not all that bright because it went
quite poorly here's what it sounded like
and again this evening the breaking news
NBC News confirming the death of Senator
John McCain our live coverage continues
on MSNBC if you can't see this they then
went back to Saturday Night Live dolphin
that love story in which two fat men
with dolphin heads are walking around
making dolphin songs sounds and then and
then proceeding to make out with each
other yeah I'm so from John McCain's
death to this well done media best gaffe
of the weekend just astonishing I mean
that so yep good well done NBC okay but
when when you look at the media's
response to all this take for example
Jake Tapper so I like Jake I'm friendly
with Jake and I think that Jake tries
his best to keep his bias out of the
politics what he says here is not
completely untrue but it is also
indicative of one of the reasons why
John McCain lost and one of the reasons
why Donald Trump won here's Jake Tapper
explaining that a lot of the reverence
you're seeing for McCain today is
because of anger at President Trump and
hatred of President Trump and Amanda for
a younger generation of conservatives
what does McCain mean and I can't help
but think that like part of the reason
why there's such reverence for him today
is because of who's in the White House
right now because they are polar
opposites yeah okay so they're that idea
that Tapper is spelling out that's
correct but it's also relevant to
mention that when John McCain was
running for the White House there was a
lot of talk about John McCain as a
nutjob who's going to land us in war
with Iran because he was a crazy person
with his finger on the trigger and then
as soon as Trump is in the White House
like oh well you know that John McCain
guy act I was great man I missed that
John McCain guy of course he missed that
John McCain guy because the guy was
never president maybe you missed that
John McCain guy because that John McCain
guy lost to your guy right Barack Obama
the media loved Barack Obama and so they
were happy with John McCain who lost in
the same way that suddenly their romance
about Mitt Romney there is even some
romance about George HW Bush's no longer
in office now is it true
the Donald Trump is a difference in kind
from John McCain from George W Bush from
Mitt Romney of course of course that's
true of course he's a difference in kind
right he's the kind of person who
refuses to keep the staff lower the flag
lowered to half-staff at the White House
out of personal peek at a dead senator
yes he's a difference in kind from those
other Republicans and it's not out of
bounds to point out that he's a
difference in kind it is important
however to recall the media malfeasance
that surrounded John McCain every time
he became a threat to the left suddenly
they turned on him and it's something to
recall about the way that the press
treat any Republican they will find
their favorite Republican treat them
well until the point when they turn at
which point as soon as they figure out
that Republicans actually Republican
that Republican becomes a bad guy again
and you see this with every major
Republican of the modern era right now
they like Ben Sasse or Ben Sasse the
senator from Nebraska to turn out to be
a Republican presidential nominee he
once again become a racist sexist pig
and homophobe that is the way the left
works it's what drove people into the
arms of President Trump in the first
place
the media is malfeasance is what allowed
President Trump to become president of
the United States which is why he
campaigns against them on a regular
basis and the media don't even recognize
this Chuck Todd was defending the media
over the weekend and he said that you
know all this mistrust in media all of
it is is it's based not in fact it's
just based on on lies and propaganda I
think one of the one of the best things
going in Donald Trump's favor we know
this is the mainstream media I hate to
say it every conservative echo-chamber
created that environment it's not it's
not no no no I mean yeah it has been a
tactic and a tool of the Roger Ailes
creative yeah so let's not pretend it's
not anything other than that you're
saying it was a creative nonsense I'm
sorry that's such nonsense that the the
belief in left media bias is a creation
of the echo chamber its whistling past
the graveyard it is just not true what
percentage of people in the NBC newsroom
actually voted for Donald Trump I would
say it verges on zero it verges on zero
the country split half in half and the
percentage verged on zero and then you
tried out folks like Roland Martin and
Roland Martin's on CNN all the time and
he says what people really want is
integrity like Obama well he's on MSNBC
here he says that well people really
want us integrity like Obama then you
wonder why people on the right think
that the media is totally full of crap
the media have been promoting here's
Roland Martin and I'll talk about this
what is happening here or you're seeing
Americans
who are saying integrity matters okay at
some point it can't be well that's just
that's just Trump being Trump no it's
not okay but it's overall and Martin
saying integrity matters they want
integrity like Obama's one of the memes
that's been going around lately is the
only scandal Obama had was his tan suit
that he wore at the White House and
members of the mainstream media been
pushing this John Harwood said this over
the weekend if you actually believe that
then it's no wonder you also believe
that people think that the media is
biased for no reason
right the me and people think the
media's biased for a very good reason
and McCain's death is the latest example
as they swiveled from McCain was a bad
guy to McCain was a good guy based on
how much damage he can do to the
Republican Party and based on who is in
the White House currently okay in just a
second
I want to talk about President Trump's
poll numbers and then a massive scandal
for the Catholic Church there's a lot
coming up and a mass shooting in
Jacksonville first let's talk about your
stamps okay the reality is that you can
go down to the post office post office
has all sorts of great services but you
probably don't want to actually spend
the time getting in the car and going
down to the post office that's why you
ought to be using stamps calm with
stamps calm you can access all the
amazing services of the post office
right from your desk 24/7 when it is
convenient for you buy and print
official US postage for any letter any
package using your own computer and
printer the mail carrier picks it up you
just click print mail you're done
couldn't be easier stamps.com is
fantastic we use it here at the Daily
wire offices you can they will actually
send you right now and use promo code
Shapiro 55 bucks of free postage in
digital scale on a four week trial so we
have the digital scale here at the
offices we use the digital scale to
weigh the mail we know the exact postage
we print the postage directly onto the
envelopes or onto a sticker that you can
affixed to the envelopes it is super
convenient it saves us time it saves us
money because time is money in our
business so stamps come go check it out
right now use promo code Shapiro for 55
bucks free postage a digital scale and a
four week trial go to stamps calm before
you do anything else click on the radio
mic at the top of the homepage and type
in Shapiro that stamps comm enter promo
code Shapiro again stamps comm promo
code Shapiro okay so with all of this
said about John McCain and President
Trump President Trump had a very bad
week last week in the media we're hoping
and hoping that this was sort of the end
of little Trump that this is going to be
the end of Donald Trump's administration
well it turns out there's a pullout and
shock of shocks the poll numbers haven't
moved at all the poll numbers are
exactly
so according to NBC in the Wall Street
Journal after a week that saw president
Donald Trump's former campaign chairman
convicted on eight counts of fraud and
his former lawyer plead guilty to felony
campaign finance charges the president's
job approval rating remains virtually
unchanged new polling from NBC News in
the Wall Street Journal shows but the
stability and trumps approval rating
also comes as more than half of voters
say he has not been honest and truthful
regarding the ongoing investigation by
Special Counsel Robert Muller and fewer
than three and ten voters are convinced
that Trump himself is not implicated in
the wrongdoing of six of his associates
who have now either been convicted of
crimes or have pled guilty
Trump's approval rating is 44 percent to
prove 52 percent disapprove that is
basically the same as it was a week ago
when it was 46% to prove 51 percent
disapprove the president's approval
ratings are extraordinarily stable I
have been saying this now for months the
president of the United States is the
beneficiary of what I call the strong
markets efficiency theory everything is
priced in there's a theory about the
stock market that you can't beat the
stock market because all available
information is immediately priced into
the price of a stock well within comes
to Donald Trump everything is priced in
except for an economic collapse
basically except for an economic
collapse or nuclear war the President of
the United States has approval ratings
will remain absolutely stable and part
of the reason for that is because we are
so ensconced in our own corners we are
now cemented in our own political
corners and one of the reasons we are so
cemented in our political corners is
indeed the bias of the media the feeling
that no matter what Trump does the media
are out to get him it wouldn't matter if
you were innocent or whether he would
guilty they would treat him exactly the
same way they went after John McCain
they went after Mitt Romney them going
after Donald Trump it was the boy who
cried wolf one too many times he can't
do it that many times and then get away
with it interminably and even if and the
thing is even when the wolf shows up
that's the moral of the story of the boy
who cried wolf is that even when the
wolf shows up nobody believes him maybe
Trump is the wolf maybe not
nobody's gonna know because the media
already shot their hog when it came to
John McCain and Mitt Romney they already
they already said all they had to say
about Republicans for years about george
w bush i've been here the whole time so
of you this is nothing new they say the
same thing about donald trump except
louder now does that mean that trumps
should justify all of that with bad
behavior of course not of course and i'd
be great if trump didn't justify all
that with bad behavior
you know people treating you badly is
not an excuse for bad behavior that said
to fail to recognize the impact of
polarized media environment on president
from stable approval ratings is
absolutely short-sighted okay meanwhile
there's over the weekend the other big
news is that there was this terrible
shooting at the madden I guess it was
Madden tournament in Jacksonville
Florida this is a gamer tournament so
basically people get together and they
play Madden for money
Madden football and the Jacksonville
Sheriff's Office has identified the
alleged shooter as a white male who had
died at the scene
he was 24 years old from Baltimore so he
was coming obviously from a gun-free
zone cuz Baltimore as we know it doesn't
have any gun control laws except for has
tons of gun control laws he died from a
self-inflicted gunshot wound inside
Chicago pizza after going on a shooting
rampage the left two dead and 11 other
people injured it was a gun-free zone
with not enough security and then this
is the typical story unfortunately of a
lot of these sorts of mass shootings
when you have a public event a popular
event popular public event you have to
have people there with guns and my
sister's wedding happened I paid
personally for security with guns to
make sure they nobody could actually get
into my sister's wedding and that was a
private event this is a major public
event that was a gun-free zone where
they didn't have enough security and
this guy got in with a gun he was a
disappointed gamer so he had gone in the
first round he lost and then he was
upset with his life that he went out and
decided to murder a bunch of people
which is just evil and sick he used at
least one handgun in his attack so a ban
on assault rifles would apparently do
nothing he'd previously appeared in a
photo with a Buffalo Bills player after
winning another competition there's been
no motive announced for the killings
there reports that he snapped after
losing an event he stayed at a local
hotel the night before the shooting
they've impounded his car the
investigation is still ongoing
EA Sports issued a statement saying we
are aware of an incident at a sanctioned
Madden Championship Series competition
in Jacksonville we are working with
authorities to gather facts at this
stage this is a horrible incident our
deepest sympathies go out to all
involved I want to point out the
hypocrisy of folks in the media who are
immediately jumping to gun control today
it's hilarious because literally five
days ago they were suggesting that it
was impossible you should not politicize
the killing of Molly Tibbets in Iowa you
should certainly not say that that has
anything to do with illegal immigration
that'll be politicization of the issue
and I discussed at length on Friday
what's true about that and what's not
true about that the fact that we know
more about Molly Tibbets is killing than
we know about the average mass shooting
in the first few days and that's why you
can say with a certain amount
certainty that illegal immigration had
something to do with the male tip it's
killing we're in this case we don't know
where he got the gun we barely know what
kind of gun the guy used we don't know
about his criminal history we don't know
his psychological history there are a
lot of other issues that conflate and
confound the media immediately jump to
gun control because it was deeply
necessary for them to push their agenda
this just shows the hypocrisy of so many
in the media who are willing to overlook
the there their ban on politicization of
major events so long as it pushes their
particular agenda the police have ID'd
this guy it does raise some questions
about the the lack of purpose in
American society there a lot of folks
today talking about relationship between
gaming and all of this that of course is
spurious this was first of all not a
violent video game so you can't even
make that connection it was it was a
football video game but the idea that
you are a professional video game player
at 24 years old and they basically our
job consists of sitting in a room alone
and playing video games I can't say I
think that that's great for society that
more and more people are doing that and
that's not a rip on people play video
games we have tons of people at the
office who play video games tons of
people who play Madden but it seems to
me that part of a well-rounded life
should be getting out a little bit more
and it appears that this guy was not
getting out a little bit more as I have
said about mass shootings before we do
have a problem of masculinity in our
society not that all masculinity is
toxic but the opposite if you do not
task young men with going out this guy's
24 I was married by the time I was 24 I
had a job by the time I was 24 years old
I graduated from law school by the time
I was 24 the fact that 24 years old in
American society now is considered a kid
that the level of responsibility that
attaches to people in their mid 20s is
basically zero they are expected to live
at home mooching off your parents not
for reasons that you have family
solidarity but just because you don't
want to pay your bills and that you do
this
all the way until you're basically 30
and then you start looking to get
married and have a family the prolonged
adolescence of young men is not good for
American society for a variety of
reasons now is that leading to an uptick
in the number of mass shootings like
this it seems like there is some basic
connection I don't think that it is the
main factor I think that there are a
bunch of factors that are that are
conflated here but to refuse to
acknowledge that young men are not being
treated with the level of responsibility
necessary from the time there are
teenagers to mature into fully blown
adult human
beings who are capable of handling their
lives is a mistake also it'll be
interesting to see what this guy's
psychological history was and how well
it was taken care of okay in just a
second I want to talk about what I think
is actually the in some ways the worst
story of the day but first we're gonna
have to go over to Daily wire calm so
for $9.99 a month you can get a
subscription to daily wire that means
you get the rest of this show it means
that you guess to get the rest of the
Android clayvin show the rest of the
Michael Noel's show if that's something
that you really want to subject yourself
to you can go check that out right now
for $9.99 a month or 499 dollars a year
get this the very finest in beverage
vessels the leftist Cheers hot or cold
tumblr go check it out right now also
check out our Sunday special by
subscribing at YouTube or iTunes got a
great one with clay Travis
last week who are we having on Sunday
I'm not sure we have a couple of
possibilities I think for Sunday we'll
announce it a little bit later this week
in any case go check it out subscribe so
you can be part of our Sunday special
and we've all sorts of great goodies
when you subscribe to the website behind
the scenes stuff and discounts and all
sorts of fun stuff so go check it out
right now we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
hey this is the worst story of the day
it really is a terrible story and it
speaks to the liberalisation of the
Catholic Church and a serious problem
with institutional protection so a few
weeks ago we talked about probably two
weeks ago we talked about the scandal
that broke out in the state of
Pennsylvania with regard to the
archdiocese in Pennsylvania covering up
over 30 years a thousand cases of child
molestation in the church and we talked
about the problems that exist within
every institution the tendency to cover
for the problems of an institution in
order to quote/unquote protect the
institution and this exists not only in
the Catholic Church it exists in various
religious communities around the country
and around the world
it exists in government's certainly it
exists in public schools there's always
the human instinct is to feel solidarity
with a particular structure you find to
be important and then whenever that
structure is threatened particularly if
it's threatened routinely you tend to
circle the wagons and defend anything
that's happening in house and this is
how you end up with the with the quiet a
sense to true evil that happens so often
around the planet you wonder how Nazi
Germany happened basically there's a
population that for bad reasons and
wrongly felt threatened by the outside
world decided to circulate basically
circle the wagons around the Nazi regime
and then the Nazi regime decided to kill
all of the enemies of the people
including the Jews and people went along
with that because the in-group was more
important than the out group and the out
group was threatening them in-group
out-group politics is deeply important
when it comes to understanding how
institutions get perverted from the
inside well now there's stories that
basically the institutional perversion
of the Catholic Church has reached up to
the top levels of the Catholic Church
this is from the the NC register the
National Catholic Register in an
extraordinary 11 page written Testament
a former apostolate apostille ik nun Co
to the United States has accused several
senior prelates of complicity in
covering up art Bishop Theodore
McCarrick
allegations of sexual abuse and has
claimed that Pope Francis knew about
sanctions imposed on then Cardinal
McCarrick by pope benedict xvi
but chose to repeal them Archbishop
Carlo Maria Vigano 77 who served as
apostolic nuncio in Washington DC from
2011 to 2016 said that in the late 2000s
Benedict had imposed on Cardinal
McCarrick sanctions similar to those now
imposed on him by Pope Francis and that
Vigano personally told Pope Francis
about those sanctions in 23rd
so McCarrick has been accused of sexual
abuse of young seminarians he's also
been accused of engaging in homosexual
acts with a bunch of people who are
under his auspices which is a violation
obviously of church code and Church
conduct and he was not turned over to
the proper authorities
the there are no allegations that the
church knew about him molesting underage
boys but if the if such allegations had
existed in the church didn't turn him
over to the secular authorities it's a
serious problem the truth is that the
the question of church justice just
historically speeching speaking
stretches back a millennium it stretches
back all the way back to when you know
Henry the second trying to say that we
should actually try priests in secular
courts in Great Britain at the very in
England in you know the in the 12th and
13th centuries
so the sort of battle between secular
and and church has been going on for a
very long time but one of the premises
of the idea the church should handle its
own business is that the church will
actually handle its own business the
church did not handle its own business
according to Archbishop Pagano he said
in his written statement simultaneously
released to the register and other media
that Pope Francis continued to cover for
McCarrick and not only did he not take
into account the sanctions that Pope
Benedict had imposed on him but also
made mckarrick his trusted counselor
Mikado's story has now been backed by a
couple of other sources
he said the former Archbishop of
Washington advised the Pope to appoint a
number of bishops in the United States
including Cardinals blade I think it's
pronounced blaze ku pitch of Chicago and
Joseph Tobin of Newark Archbishop Pagano
who said his conscience dictates the
truth be known as the corruption has
reached the very top of the church's
hierarchy ended his testimony by calling
on Pope Francis and all those implicated
in the cover-up of Archbishop Makarios
abuse to resign the accusation basically
suggests that McCarrick has abused
legitimately dozens of people the media
has reported written written reports of
victims of abuse spanning decades
including a teenage boy three young
priests or seminarians and a man now in
his 60s who alleges that McCarrick
abused him from the age of eleven the
Pope later accepted mechanic's
resignation from the College of
Cardinals but Vigano wrote the Benedick
much earlier had imposed sanctions on
mckarrick similar to those handed down
by Cardinal parolin the Cardinal was to
leave the seminary where he was living
he was forbidden to celebrate Mass in
public to participate in public meetings
to give lectures to travel with the
obligation of dedicating himself to a
life of prayer and
he said the sanctions were applied as
far back as 2009 2010 Benedict's measure
came years after archbishop Madonna's
predecessor at the nunciature
had immediately informed the Holy See as
soon as they had learned of Archbishop
Makarios gravely immoral behavior with
seminarians and priests basically the
accusation here is that all of these
memos were ignored by the top levels of
the of the College of Cardinals and the
papacy McDonald claims he wrote several
memos to a series of Cardinals who
repeatedly refused to do anything about
this they basically gave in to what he
essentially calls a homosexual clique in
the Catholic Church Logano says that he
personally repeated the sanction to
mckarrick and the Cardinal muttering in
a barely comprehensible way admitted he
perhaps made the mistake of sleeping in
the same bed with some seminarians at
his beach house but he said this as if
it had no importance Vigano says in his
testimony apparently Pope Francis knew
about all of this he said it was clear
that from the time of Pope Francis's
election McCarrick now free from all
constraints had felt free to travel
continuously
Seve lectures and interviews he said
mckarrick who backed Pope Francis became
the kingmaker for appointments in the
Curia and the United States and the most
listened to advisor in the Vatican for
relations with the Obama administration
he says that appointments about their
Cardinals were orchestrated by mckarrick
it is a massive massive scandal and
Catholics are in there there are a lot
of traditional Catholics who are looking
at this and wondering if Pope Francis
can actually survive this whether Pope
Francis should step down for having
helped to cover all of this up because
Pope Francis has been extraordinarily
soft on LGBT issues it's something media
have taken note of for a very long time
and there's a feeling among traditional
Catholics that perhaps his softness on
those issues led him to basically look
the other way with regard to this
Archbishop McCarrick who's actually
engaged in violations of Catholic code
with other seminarians alongside
allegations of him molesting underage
kids really really troubling stuff but
again any institution that refuses to
cleanse itself is going to pay the price
for all of this do you Pope Francis
tweeted out something insane about this
he tweeted out something like he prays
for the victims he prays to Mary for the
victims and it's like dude you're the
Pope now it's time for you to actually
do something about it right you're seems
like you could be in a position to help
God out here I mean I'm not I'm not a
Catholic but it seems like if you're the
Pope you might be in a position to
actually you know help cleanse the
Catholic Church of this stuff as opposed
to just
vague references to prayer I I'm not
usually person who says that prayer is
not an answer but when it comes to you
having the power to do something about
this at the head of a church to cleanse
your own church of this stuff you're
gonna need to do more than pray about
this one a time God this one's on the
church and after and this is true for
Jewish communities and Catholic
communities and Protestant communities
and Muslim communities it is true for
every community a community that fails
to cleanse itself of evil is a community
that that becomes complicit in that evil
okay meanwhile a lot of controversy
today breaking out over Tiger Woods what
did Tiger Woods do that was so awful
that was so terrible so apparently he
was asked about after his final round of
the Northern Trust about his
relationship with President Trump and
here's what he said he said well I've
known Donald for a number of years
he said we played golf together we've
had dinner together I've known him pre
presidency and obviously during his
presidency and then he was asked about
being threatened by Trump in his policy
when would said well he's the president
of the United States you have to respect
the office matter who's in the office
you may like dislike personality or the
politics but we must all respect the
office and then asked if he had any more
to say about the state and discourse of
race relations would said no I just
finished 72 holes I'm hungry and this of
course led to a massive controversy why
isn't Tiger Woods such a powerful voice
speaking up on issues of race relations
Tiger Woods is the reason people are
still watching sports gay people had
stopped watching golf because Tiger
Woods became a relevant Tiger Woods is
relevant again and people are watching
the last thing Tiger Woods should be
doing is talking about politics in
sports you want to destroy the last
common area we have left in common
destroy the sporting world by polarizing
it around issues of politics suggest
that every celebrity has the necessity
to talk about every political issue
Under the Sun there's kind of a running
joke on Twitter these days about Taylor
Swift because Taylor Swift has basically
stayed out of politics as well and so
anytime there's some sort of issue
people will start joking Taylor Swift's
silence on this issue is deafening
because the the joke is that the media
expects all these public figures who
have nothing to do they're not famous
from politics to start sounding off
about politics because celebrity
dominates our politics it's really bad
president from tweeted out about this is
a 17 he tweeted out the fake a news
media we're tired to get Tiger Woods to
say something he didn't want to say
Tiger wouldn't play the game he's very
smart more importantly he's playing
great golf again
okay so President Trump is
right about this it's not particularly
smart to him to draw attention to it
because now Tiger Woods is going to be
badgered beyond belief by the media even
more than he was before and now it looks
as though Tiger is tacitly supporting
the president which will force him to
come out and say something against the
president you can see how this is
exactly going to play out right you can
see how this is gonna work
Trump says something Tigers now forced
into a corner to say he doesn't like a
lot of Trump's policies from turns on
Tiger it turns into a Trump vs. Tiger
fight which maybe is what Trump wants
out of all of this maybe it's not what
he wants maybe he doesn't care and he
just tweet stuff out but the bottom line
is did Tiger do the right thing
yes Tiger did the right thing on our
Sunday special this week we had on Clay
Travis Clay Travis sports commentator
and he has a new book coming out called
Republicans by sneakers - which is a
line from Michael Jordan because during
the 1990s Michael Jordan didn't get
political and a lot of the people in the
media wanted him to get political he
said listen Republicans buy sneakers
also why would I a lien ate half of the
population there's no reason for me to
do that Tiger Woods made the right move
here it is none of Tiger Woods's purview
to talk politics he's not an expert on
the issue but we have this weird
tendency in American life now to think
that everybody is an expert on
everything and the more prominent you
are in any field the more you are an
expert on something so you'll see people
who have become very rich in the hedge
fund area and suddenly we think they're
experts on politics I mean this is why
Trump is president right Trump is not an
expert on politics Trump actually
doesn't know all that much about
politics he has some gut level instincts
many of which are good some of which are
not good but people think he's an expert
because he's very rich we want we all
now abide by the line from Fiddler on
the Roof there's a there's a line in if
I were a rich man where Tevye is singing
tight via the the peddler is singing and
he and he's talking about what it's like
to be rich and he says the the most
important men in town will come to call
on me they'll come and they'll ask me
questions and they'll ask questions that
would cross a rabbis eyes and it doesn't
matter if I answer right or wrong when
you're rich they think you really know
and that's exactly right I mean this is
the way that our politics works now
Tiger Woods is very good at golf so we
think he should say something about
politics because he must know he mustn't
know about the intricacies of race
relations because Tiger Woods hits a
golf ball for a living now LeBron James
must know everything there is to know
about politics and have important things
to say on politics because he's very
famous and because he plays basketball
and this is not saying that he should
shut up and dribble he can say whatever
he wants it's our fault that we
polit that we take celebrity seriously
not their fault if celebrities want to
talk that's their issue but if you want
to alienate half the population if you
want to drive people up a wall if you
want ESPN to continue declining in the
ratings
please keep asking Tiger Woods what he
thinks of President Trump let's do that
let's do a lot of that you want to
destroy what's left of our common
culture all you have to do is keep
pushing this idea that our celebrities
should be spokespeople for the policies
that you particularly like it's ugly
stuff and it makes for a worse country
which is why ESPN is declining in the
ratings that's why people are watching
less and less of sports and it's why the
media's focus on the politicization of
every angle of sports is actually making
star secondary I'm a baseball fan you
know many baseball fans want to see more
of Mike Trout on TV the answer is
virtually every baseball fan we can't
even see Mike Trout on TV anymore
because we're busy battling out kneeling
for the national anthem an issue that
has really very little bearing on
anybody's life when the continuation of
this polarization is only gonna make our
politics worse I think things are likely
to get worse before they get better in
American life and that's not a good
thing that's that's a that's a very
dangerous thing okay it's time for some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so let's get to some things that
I like this is so over the weekend Neil
Simon died so it wasn't just John McCain
Neil Simon died at the age of 91
he is am obviously one of the kind of
great American playwrights and his most
famous play was The Odd Couple which was
made into a movie with Jack Lemmon and
Walter Matthau it's a hysterically funny
movie a particular the first half of the
movie is really really funny here's a
little bit of the trailer for The Odd
Couple starring Jack Lemmon
on hypochondria
a fussbudget neater the neat cleaner
than please no wonder his wife kicked
him out hmm
that's not bad honey what are you doing
I'm trying to clear up my ears and open
up fat yeah they think I sprained my
throat Walter Matthau another guy whose
wife left him and his pad looks like she
left it a long time ago who wants food
what do you got I got brown sandwiches
and green sandwiches we're 21 what's the
green see the very new cheese or very
old meat I'll take the brown eye it is
it's a really funny movie and it's it's
worth watching he also did the maybe
we'll do a Neil Simon this week like a
bunch of Neil Simon stuff because
there's a bunch of great Neil Simon
plays that that he did that are really
funny and really good and so we'll check
some of that out this week The Odd
Couple is his best and you should
definitely check Walter Matthau is just
fantastic in the part Jacqueline and
Walter Matthau have great chemistry
which is why they were still doing
grumpy old men all the way up till the
time when they were in fact grumpy old
men okay
the the okay other things that let's
just do a thing that I hate right here
so things that I hate The Daily Mirror
is now pushing man bras I am not kidding
you man
bras okay and here is what they are
saying they're saying lacey bras for men
are now a thing and you can also buy
matching knickers okay k and i ck ers
okay it's a British word hey I did not
just say racial slur I just want to make
that absolutely clear because I would
never say a racial slur like that but I
want to make absolutely clear so Media
Matters doesn't suggest that I would
ever say a racial slur because I just
pronounced a word for undergarments in
in in British okay so I just want
because that's the way that this
industry works now so here is what the
here's what the Daily Mirror says ladies
if you've ever looked at your man's
underwear and thought it was a bit dull
then you're not alone hey I don't know a
single lady who has ever looked at men's
underwear and thought it was a bit dull
they say there's so much choice when it
comes to women's underwear from
to Brazilian and Bridget Jones style
pants not to mention strapless multi-way
and water bras most men have only boxers
or briefs to choose from you know why
because women don't operate with regard
to sex the same way that men do they
don't okay women aren't like the men
we'll check out pretty much any women
that is moving because that is
evolutionarily but it's it's
evolutionarily beneficial for men to
check out women and women's don't think
about sex in exactly the same way which
is why men find the unclothed female
body a lot more attractive than women
find the unclothed male body as a
general rule this is not to say that
women aren't into sex but it is to say
that you compare men's view of sex to
women's view of sex is obviously
ridiculous and it's one of the reasons
why prostitution is a largely is an
industry that almost entirely caters to
male and why pornography is an industry
then almost entirely caters to males in
any case we're now going to try to
pretend that women are exactly the same
about sex as men are and that women are
into men dressing like ladies which is
real weird
so the Daily Mirror says this is all
about to change as one lingerie company
has created a unique line of bras and
undergarments going to change the word
especially for men Hey hum Mystere is
selling lacey bras matching underwear
and for the male who wants to wear
something a little more sexy under his
clothes as if that's not enough men can
get their own silken ids baby dolls and
body suits no no this is according to
the website it's not just the men
getting a kick out of the soft luxurious
underwear the women love it too okay
quick survey of the women in the room is
this something that you're into just you
need to stop vomiting back there why are
you vomiting hey into the trashcan
please no women are not into this I love
that I love that people actually posted
reviews of this and we're not
embarrassed as a review posted for the
turquoise Annabelle bra said so sexy my
girlfriend loves me in this and the
matching panties then let me suggest
that your girlfriend may in fact be into
other types of things as well okay like
if you're dressing a man as a lady maybe
she's just into the ladies because this
is not a thing it's not even close to a
thing one man reviewing the Tiffany
sleepwear set commented the material
feels so soft and sensuous to the touch
and feels so on and feel so comfortable
you could sleep in at all night if it
wasn't so sexy okay
I got nothing I got nothing
daily mail thank you for that I'm glad
that you've made the world a
significantly worse place today and it
was already an unbelievably crappy place
after the news of the weekend
the equation of men and women with
regard to sex is one of the Dumber
things on the agenda of feminists and
radical leftists this idea that women
treat men's bodies the same way that men
treat women's bodies is essentially
insane it's essentially insane it's just
crazy because men and women's brains do
not treat sex the same way and to
pretend that what women really want out
of men is for men to be more feminine is
is totally nuts
it's totally crazy there's not there's
not a straight woman alive who wants men
to be who wants men to be more feminine
just as there is no straight man alive
who's interested in women being really
really masculine what I really want my
wife to be is more like a man okay
that's not a thing so the separation of
sexist is one of the great things about
life and the attempt to destroy that
with stupidities like this the truth is
that the Daily Mail is just looking for
clickbait and they got it I had to give
it attention because it's so insane but
it's we need okay we need to stop
showing these pictures because it's just
too horrifying it's just too terrible
all the way all the way around is the
audio working again or is it or is it
still out of commission it's still okay
fine so we all have to break here today
we'll save some of our goodies for
tomorrow but we will be back then I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah al Vera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018